so you and a few people in the squadron
either detected ufos on your instruments
or saw them directly
tell me the full story of these ufo
sightings
and uh to the smallest technical details
because i love those i'll do my best
so
we returned from and when i say we i
mean my not my squadron but vfa11 the
red rippers uh i was a
a somewhat junior pilot at the time i
joined them on deployment 2012
where they had been already out there
for about six months or so
um
operating in the vicinity of afghanistan
uh i joined them and then we we flew
back and still as a relatively new guy
we came back and we entered what's
considered a maintenance phase where we
slow down the tactical flying a bit uh
kind of recuperate
do some maintenance on the aircraft and
our particular model of the f-18 the lot
the lot number
was plumbed
for
the particular things that were needed
to upgrade the radar from what's known
as the abg-73 to the apg-79
and the apg-73 is a mechanically
scanned array radar uh
it's a you know perfectly fine radar but
the ace of radar is kind of a you know
magnitude jumping capability kind of an
analog digital kind of mindset so got it
so it's a leap to digital
uh avg 73 so i mean are these things on
a carrier like what are we talking about
here this is how big is the radar yeah
so this is actually the radar it's in
the f-18 itself
okay so when you say that we're chosen
this is to test
uh the upgrade to the new the 79 abg 79.
less of an uh test and more of just hey
it's your turn to get the upgrade like
we're all going to these better radars
um they were building ones off the off
the line with the new radar but we were
this weird transitionary squadron in the
middle that transitioned from the older
ones to the new ones
but it's not particularly rare to fly
with different types of radar because in
the and we call the fleet replacement
squadron essentially the training ground
for the f-18 you have all sorts of f-18s
with different radar so
you are used to having multiple ones but
in the actual deployable
combat squadron
we upgraded and when we upgraded we saw
that there were objects on the radar
that we were seeing the next day in in
this with this new radar that weren't
there with the old radar and these were
sometimes you know the same day you
might go on two flights the one in the
morning might be with the older radar
the one the evening with the new radar
and you and you'd see the objects with
the with the new radar and that's not
overly surprising in some sense uh they
are more sensitive uh perhaps they're
not filtering out everything they should
be yet or perhaps there's some other
type of error
uh maybe it needs to be calibrated
whatever it was relatively new and we
were somewhat used to there being
software problems with these types of
things occasionally just like anything
else
and so okay maybe this is a radar
software malfunction we're getting some
false tracks as we call them
um
what were you seeing
and so what we would see are
representations of the object so this is
off of our radar we're not seeing a
visual image here this is kind of like
what's being displayed to us almost like
in a gaming fashion right like our the
icon right so the icon is showing us hey
something is there and here's the
parameters i can understand about it so
this is in the cockpit there's a display
that's showing
um some visualization with the radar is
detecting correct
and there's two different ways to do
that the first one is like the actual
data like the radar where
um
i am
it's showing me the data kind of as it
fits in front of me and i'm selecting
those contacts and there's another
screen called the situational awareness
page and that's kind of a god's eye view
that brings all that data into one spot
and so
i'm going to talk about this from the sa
page from the situational awareness page
versus the individual radar ones because
it's easier but okay sorry to linger on
that so the individual displays are like
first person
and then the essay
is
when you say god's eye view is like from
the top integration of all the
information
as if it's looking down onto the earth
yes is that a good way to summarize it
is but for the aviator it's slightly
different because those two radar
displays i talked about are at the
bottom of that display
is kind of representable where i am and
so i see what's in front of me got it
whereas the situational awareness page
uh the aircraft is located in the center
of that
and then i all around me you know
based off of the data link and wherever
i'm getting information from
i can see that whole where page i can
see all the situation so
i'm going to kind of talk about this
from the situational awareness page
which is a top-down view just to kind of
frame our minds instead of jumping
around
and so what we would see out there is
we'd see these indications that
something would be there and they would
have a track file
that track file that thing that
represents the object has a line coming
out of it and that represents that's
called the target aspect indicator
um and there's some tracking from the
radar correct so it's showing you where
the object's going this is all pretty
cool that the radar can do all this so
radar locks in on the different objects
and attracts them over time correct
that's coming from the radar that's like
built-in feature
okay cool out there we're seeing it yes
we don't have to necessarily like pull
things into our
our tracker in some sense right like
it's all out there and then we can kind
of choose the highlight on stuff or to
kind of focus in on it more so uh but
the information should all be out there
and so we'd see that target aspect
indicator that that line on a typical
aircraft you know it would kind of look
like this it'd be coming out and it goes
steady and if they turn you you know
it'll be like
when you see them turn right like it's
not magic but this object they would the
target aspect would kind of
be like all over the place like kind of
randomly in the 360 degrees you know
from that top-down view that line would
be
in a place so kind of you know is it
unable to determine the target aspect is
it stationary you know and that's just
how it puts it out and it's not used to
seeing it so i'm not saying that's
necessarily super weird but it was
different than what we were used to
seeing because we weren't used to seeing
stationary objects out there very much
um and what was also interesting is that
these weren't just stationary
on a zero wind day right these are
stationary at twenty thousand feet 15
000 feet
500 feet
you know with with the wind blowing you
know
and so much like the sea you know when
we're up there fighting it affects
everything we consider the wind when
we're you know shooting missiles when
we're flying or fuel considerations it's
like operating you know in that volume
of air like the ocean everything's going
with the current
and so anything that doesn't go with the
current you know is immediately
kind of identifiable and strange and
that's why these were initially
strangers because they would be
stationary against the wind so if you
had something like a good drone
in the windy conditions what would that
look like would it it would not come off
as stationary would it sort of float
about kind of thing no i think what the
drone technology would have today they
could stay within a pretty tight
location well i meant like dji drone not
like cons i'm saying like generically
speaking i would not i'm not a military
drone no i have a dji drone myself even
and you know maybe not 100 knots but if
that thing's in 30 or 40 not wins you
know
the amount of
distance it's going to be kind of doing
one of these like that change is not
something i'm going to detect from maybe
many miles away interesting so it could
look very stationary
but that wasn't necessarily and what's
interesting about this story is that
there's not like the one smoking gun
right you have to kind of look at
everything and that's what you know i
don't like about um
the department of defense and just
generally people's take on this is that
everything is kind of based around a
single image you know or that that one
case but a lot of interestingness comes
from the duration or the time it's been
out there how they're interacting
relative to other objects out there and
you don't get that information when you
just look at a frame for a second you
know everyone kind of bites off on the
shiny object but so you yourself or from
your particular slice of things you've
experienced and seen directly or
indirectly you've kind of built up an
intuition about what uh the things that
were being seen i want to go that far
i've just been able to you know
eliminate some some variables because of
how long i've observed it so like you
said yes can a drone stay in a
particular position against the wind
like that certainly but i don't think it
can do that and then go point eight mach
for four hours after that you know and
so when you when you look at outside of
that once that moment in time then it
eliminates a lot of the potential things
it could be at least from my perspective
so what kind of stuff did you see yeah
in the instruments we'd see them flying
um in patterns kind of racetrack
patterns or circular patterns or just
going kind of straight east
i
occasionally see them supersonic 1.1 1.2
mach but typically 0.6 to 0.8 mach just
for
extremely extended periods of time you
know essentially all the time
and this is airspace where there's not
supposed to be anything else at all um
and it's pretty far out there it starts
10 miles off the coast goes like 300
miles can you say the location that
we're talking about off the coast of
virginia beach
got it and so nobody is supposed to be
out there
it's possible for people to be there
it's not necessarily restricted but it's
well monitored and we're out there every
day all day and so you know people know
to stay clear if a cessna goes bumbling
in there everyone's going to know about
it fa is going to you know call him out
he's going to tell us about it so
um
concursions happen not a big deal but um
they're pretty rare honestly because
everyone knows area and we've been
operating there for decades and what are
the trajectories at 0.6 to 0.8 mach that
these objects were taking
typically they would be in some type of
circular pattern or kind of racetrack
pattern when they were at those beads or
i just see them kind of it wasn't always
like a mechanical flight
description and when i say that i mean
like an autopilot is going to be
just very precise right it's going to be
locked on straight and whereas i could
see an airplane i could tell if the
pilot's flying it right because it's not
going to be perfect
the computer's not controlling it and
these seemed more like that not that
they were imprecise but that they were
even much more erratic than that so like
it wasn't like a straight line in a turn
it was just kind of like a
you know weird drift like that in that
direction you know so it wasn't
controlled by a dumb computer or uh no
no disrespect to computers so it wasn't
controlled by autopilot kind of
technology that's not the sense that i
got
you